il
m
et
pas besoin d'aller très loin de chez soi
pour s'éclater en freestyle en vtt on
the run le nouveau team pour la
valorisation du vtt du bmx et d'autres
sports cyclistes le prouve en
réhabilitant des pistes oubliées un peu
partout dans l'île
aujourd'hui direction pichette à la
possession à deux pas des habitations et
du goudron pour une descente en pleine
forêt glissante et aérienne waouh la
possession c'est démoniaque allez on y
va avec jérôme payet disons de vélo
plusieurs fois champion de la réunion
classé parmi les dix meilleurs français
alors c'est un endroit qui était
approprié par les jeunes d'ici 1
les jeunes processionné saïdis qui a
évolué au fil des années un
ça a commencé facile c'est devenu plus
en plus difficile avec les conditions
métérologiques aujourd'hui avec un petit
peu de booba sera agrémenté la chose ça
change un peu de terrain c'est top coin
pour débuter une bonne initiation masse
et le top de faire des petits spots pas
de chez soi
ce spot l'haÿ les roses idéal comme je
vous dis plusieurs niveaux de
l'initiation aux experts de la ligne
droite pour plein de petits virages
comme vous avez vu
j'aime ce sport il déjà il aime le
dépassement personnel c'est déjà eu je
parle plutôt promosport spécifique la
descente du coup en compte personne
n'était contre le chronomètre au final
messi comme en cause de l'automobile au
rallye automobile soit route
leur sort
m
durant le tout
pourquoi pratiquer à 2 parce que des
fois tu peux même pu téléphoner si tu
arrives une grosse gamelle
et normalement si on connaît bien les
bases qui appâte risqué
soit parfait
gfr
entre